This conception, we talked about this a little bit yesterday in our section of
sort of putting the
community goals or whatever goals ahead of your own personal goals and if
your sort of a, if your an economist or game theorist you could
you could certainly explain it as somebody actually putting their own personal goals but fitting them to a
longer time frame. So, I don't know what my comment
really is, but
it seems like there is a
another appropriate economic explanation that goes beyond religious convictions or values based convictions in that case. Just curious what your, your thoughts are.
Right, so, so, so that
we may, each of us may have
some stake
in being a kind of
longer-term
altruist because your interest is bound up with
the with the community's interest and
therefore whatever you do for the community
you'll, it's, it's a
irrational generosity on your part
but rather it, it is very rationally
thought through
conception of how the whole
fits together and your place in it and your good is bound up with the good of others
and therefore you ought to promote it, right
there are
we can, yes please. Okay, I guess a question I'd like to sort of touch on is looking at leaders in the market who do not, who are not religious, and how they can sort of develop the
similar moral base that their colleagues
or other market leaders who are religious,
so that they can work together to achieve similar goals
whether or not they are a Christian faith.
In a sense that's, that's going in Joel's direction, so that the kind of
concern for the common good
may not necessarily, need not necessarily come
from religious traditions or need not be
based deeply on some altruistic motives,
but rather could come could come from other
sources, but that, in fact, you may have then
overlapping convictions
and would be able possibly to work some
of us justifying it in one way
others of us justifying it in different
way but nonetheless you would have
at least significantly overlapping conceptions
of something like the common
global common good. There was a